final season of Teen Wolf yes
oh my goodness okay so what can we
expect we can expect a lot of blood
sweat and tears a new relationship yes
and I think all of our questions will be
answered there's always going to be
stuff where you're gonna be where you're
going to be left hanging on just just
some minor things because the way I want
Teen Wolf to progress is that maybe we
come back one day as a movie or
something a TV show again who knows I in
my heart would love that to happen so I
kind of want to leave a little couple of
small things left open but we do get a
really nice wrap up of everybody and
everything and it's all the all the
really diehard fans are gonna love it
it's for them I'm kind of dating myself
because I am of you know the Michael J
Fox team a generation which I love so
when I knew that it was coming back in
you and you guys were doing it I was
like I don't know but boy was I wrong ya
know everybody said the same thing I
said the same thing I you know I was a
big fan of Michael J Fox growing up as a
kid I mean I didn't say much I was born
in 91
so that was way after his career it our
way hold on hold on
Oh get the defibrillator over here clear
um so I felt a little odd too but the
second I read the script I had the same
reaction when you saw the show I'm like
damn we're doing something way different
it's darker it's edgy er it's a lot
cooler or it's deeper and I think we did
a pretty good job at turning it into
something new but still you know getting
remembrance to the actual movie
you